Ben you said earlier that being a
director is being a captain of a ship
and managing chaos and I understand that
one of your actresses was out of
commission so how did that happen and
how did you not let everything fall
apart or maybe it did for a day right
okay so we had the we intended to shoot
a movie in 12 days which I did the day
we did but with the one month stop in
production so the thing is we shudder
six first days of food and then our lead
actress broke her collarbone on set
which of course in the moment was a sad
thing to go through for all of us
because we were so any together and you
know what actually to get back and said
it was pretty easy I remember that I
mean the lead actress wanted to go back
so bad because she was so committed and
everyone was so committed that I think I
we went back and I sent an email like
five days only after that asking for
people would be available in one month
to n and people were like all the actors
and all the crew was so committed and
involved to tell the story and they
lacked the first part of the movie so
much that they were like of course we
want to go back and so we were just wait
then within one month and people went
back and said and we did the six other
days of shoot well not after so pretty
much it was it was actually simple to
get everybody back and said because
people people were so it was such a
cohesive mood I mean atmosphere and
people were so committed to telling the
story that of course they wanted to
finish the story to tell the story how
did you handle it when let so so I'm
assuming she went to the hospital and
you don't know what's happening you
didn't know how maybe how committed
everyone was right so that 24 hours or
however long how are you dealing with
that it was a
you see both her in pain and to see the
film stopped it's like the two most
awful pain pains but I have such a
nature of just overcoming things that I
was I put myself into the future and I
was like okay we have to make it work
and we have to start rearing the film
toward its end and so yeah we I I had
this yeah I'd say less than 24 hours
moment of doubt of course but I because
the instinct was to finish the film I
just decided to just go beyond it to go
beyond doubt and the pain and just to
get everybody on board again so your
advice to another filmmaker that right
it sounds like when you're all in on
something you're like a hundred and ten
percent exactly exactly yeah there's no
Sami so what's your advice to another
filmmaker that maybe doesn't have that
strong of a resolve but could if they
had the right pep talk sure well don't
let go of anything just don't stop
anything there is nothing which will
stop your movie if you have the right
people with you so be sure you who you
have in your crew in your cast but
especially in your crew have good and
legitimate producer have a good and
legitimate line producer have a great
first ad which you can tell anything to
and who will do anything for the sake of
the movie to help you go through this
road so it's I mean in la there are a
lot of people call themself producers
because they have like this small credit
like on IMVU or some of the stuff or
don't even have anything and just stay
away from that and I know that finding
the legitimate people takes time and and
that's the hardest part if you have
illegitimate people board you will fail
and even if you are somebody who is a
great soul lining and tries to overcome
everything if you have a legit a
legitimate people and i'm not talking
about only bad vibrations or this kind
of stuff but unprofessional people you
won't make it so be sure of who you have
in your crew be sure of who you have in
your cast and then it it would be pretty
easy to follow up with this kind of crew
and cast
you